joining us now is Missouri Senator Eric
Schmidt Senator um good news Friday and
on this immigration
deal do you sense that this is actually
going to make it with this compromise
and negotiation supposedly in the
works well I don't know um I think that
we heard yesterday that Chuck Schumer
may put this on the floor next week now
no one's seen any language um and I
think again that speaks to the uh the
design here which is to keep people in
the dark and then to Spur it on people
so they don't have time to look at any
of this stuff but here's what we do know
right now Laur and you touched on it
with your intro first of all Joe Biden
has every Authority right now to close
the border if he wanted to he could
reinstate remain in Mexico was which was
working under President Trump he won't
do that he could stop abusing and
misusing parole which is supposed to be
individual adjudications not entire
classifications that's accounted for
millions of people coming across
illegally dispersed in in the interior
of the United States we have no idea
where they are who they are maybe they
have a court date 7 eight years from now
he could do that but he won't because
Joe Biden the Democrats are full-blown
open borders now this is what they
believe it's in their DNA they're not
going to change that because of some
language change and some sort of
compromise Bill secondly um you know
we've been left in the dark like I
mentioned uh the language is supposed to
be so complex we have to wait till we
actually see it which I appreciate that
but don't SC this on last minute no no
right and I think to your point what
they always
do mhm yeah and and I think that that
here I'm just going to say the truth of
this is for many right now in the Senate
and in Congress this is just an attempt
to unlock the Ukraine money right to
have something that people can say
there's enough here to unlock the
Ukraine money which is wildly unpopular
among Republicans it's losing support
even in the Republican conference in the
United States Senate and so let's just
call for what it is a way to get to
unlock the Ukraine money I think a lot
of people are now calling BS on this
um but look Joe Biden could close the
border now that's the truth he won't do
it so whatever this language change is
he's proven he's not interested in it's
not going to change the reality on the
ground yeah Senator it's irrelevant like
the I'm sorry but the
details of this so-called negotiated
bill which I submit was written months
ago the details sadly do not matter
because there is zero good faith on the
part of Democrats the Border if they
wanted to enforce the Border if if if
Trump was an existential threat and they
wanted to take an issue away from him
they would enforce the Border they don't
give a rip because open borders is their
policy period end of story and any
Republican trying to tell uh the
American people anything different
should be defeated and primar and I'm
going to personally make sure that I I
work toward that yeah and the truth is
look under existing law we had a secure
border under President Trump that's what
you need to know and if we don't pass
anything here guess what we're going to
have under President Trump a secure
border so this is all again uh to your
point a very elaborate Ru to talk about
these language changes to ultimately
unlock the 60 plus billion dollars for
Ukraine they're already talking about
another 100 billion after that for an
endless war and a blank check I think
people have had enough of
this that the American people do not
approve of look at all the polling they
don't want this they wish Ukraine good
luck but this is not what the American
people are clamoring for our border
first and then we'll look at helping
other countries borders Senator you've
been terrific on this hold firm thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else